Tradutor: Yza Ferreira
Revisor: Maricene Crus
O tema que eu trago
pra compartilhar com vocês hoje
é um tema instigante pro ser humano,
porque o tema da liberdade,
ele é instigante porque,
muito embora do ponto de vista antológico,
ou seja, quando nós vamos analisar
profundamente a realidade do ser
ou a realidade das coisas,
a liberdade não exista,
nós a inventamos pra não enlouquecer.
Nós criamos uma série de elementos,
pra criar um tipo de codificação
social que pudesse
facilitar o entendimento
do que é ser livre.
Então, nós temos a liberdade do ser,
a liberdade de expressão,
a liberdade política.
E nós valorizamos muito esse espaço
construído socialmente,
mas lá no fundo existe
um momento em que é muito mais definidor
da minha liberdade, da liberdade do outro,
quando eu sou capaz
ou em que medida eu vivo o mundo,
em que medida eu experimento esse mundo,
e como eu vejo o outro
nesse mundo que eu experimento.
Essa vai ser a medida
que vai nos dar a ideia real
se nós estamos próximas ou próximos
ou afastados desse código da liberdade.
Então...
Com isso, porque nós acabamos
de criar algo que não existe,
pra experimentar concretamente em nós
e socialmente a liberdade,
nós habitamos profundamente um paradoxo
que é o paradoxo mais maravilhoso,
o mais fundamental talvez
da existência humana,
que é esse paradoxo
entre esses dois polos incríveis.
Em um polo aqui, nós temos
essa experiência do finito,
do infinito dentro do ser.
Isso de tempos imemoriais.
Vocês todos devem se lembrar,
quando lá, nos primórdios,
a gente olhava pro céu e experimentava
e tentava compreender algo
que era o desconhecido,
que era o infinito desconhecido.
Essa experiência, nós começamos
com uma mística,
e depois fomos pra ciência,
numa tentativa de trazer
esse infinito pra dentro do finito.
Só que nós já sabemos que isso
é literalmente impossível.
Muitas dessas cabeças, desses braços
e dessas pernas do infinito
ficaram de fora de mim,
ficam de fora de mim,
porque a minha finitude é incompatível
com a colocação desse infinito
e desse desconhecido todo em mim.
Especialmente porque...
Quando nós pensamos no Hubble,
que foi um cara que a gente tem até
um telescópio em homenagem a ele,
lá nos anos de 1936,
ele disse o seguinte:
"A astronomia é o estudo de um horizonte
que sempre se afasta".
Então quanto mais nós tentamos
colocar esse infinito pra dentro,
o nosso filtro foi sempre:
"O que desse infinito eu posso pôr?"
"O que desse infinito eu reconheço?"
Tinha sempre o filtro
da minha própria moral:
"Como eu posso pôr alguma coisa
que é absolutamente desconfortável
ou absolutamente desconfortante
pra dentro de mim,
quando eu busco, na verdade,
uma mínima estabilização?"
Vocês entendem?
É uma situação extremamente complexa
essa de fazer esse movimento
de trazer o infinito pra cá,
o infinito pra dentro do ser.
E tem o outro polo,
que é bastante gigante,
que é quando a gente fez o contrário,
e Platão já dizia isso.
Platão dizia:
"A minha alma me força a olhar pro céu,
a olhar pra cima,
e sair de mim e ir atrás do desconhecido".
Isso a gente sabe, a história toda
que aconteceu após Platão,
o tanto que foi contido esse impulso
da natureza da alma
de investigar e de fluir no infinito.
Nós sabemos.
Não tem 500 anos que a gente ainda pensava
que a Terra era o centro
de todo o Universo.
Essa condição do ser
se projetar no infinito,
ela é bastante...
belicosa.
Ela exige muita coragem.
Ela exige muita disposição,
pra você poder abrir mão de um circuito,
onde você relativamente se conhece,
pra pisar fora dele
e invadir esse desconhecido.
E não esperar que algo do desconhecido,
que você permite entrar em você,
adentre esse seu círculo.
Essa é uma medida de extrapolar.
É onde eu comuniquei pra mim mesma
que é o meu trajeto
do conhecido pro desconhecido
que vai me realizar.
Com isso,
nós criamos duas matrizes,
e nessas duas matrizes,
toda experiência de liberdade
do ser humano se assenta
ou toda experiência de aprisionamento
do ser humano se assenta.
Na experiência onde eu trago
o infinito pra dentro de mim,
que é uma experiência basicamente
intelectual do desconhecido,
em contrapartida com a experiência
onde eu, meu conhecido, se lança
numa viagem pelo desconhecido,
que é uma experiência completamente
espiritual da liberdade.
E por favor, não me entendam mal,
espiritual eu não quero dizer
de forma nenhuma nada místico
e nem tampouco
necessariamente algo religioso,
mas o simples fato de eu poder fluir
com o impulso da minha alma.
Então, nessa matriz,
nós geramos um problema muito
conhecido pra quem é médico,
pra quem é psicólogo
e pra nós que somos amigos
e amantes das pessoas.
Nós geramos um tipo
de paranoia do "estar bem",
e certamente vocês conhecem
isso que eu estou dizendo.
São pessoas que precisam o tempo todo
estar na sua zona de conforto.
São pessoas que não podem abdicar
de uma satisfação emocional imediata.
São, na verdade,
seres humanos muito infantis.
Esses seres humanos...
Talvez a caricatura mais perfeita dele,
é uma pessoa que nos seus 70, 80 anos,
tem um minuto de lucidez,
olha pra trás e fala o seguinte:
"Os mais difíceis anos da minha vida
foram os 50 primeiros
anos da minha infância".
Então...
é um depoimento triste,
mas é um momento de lucidez.
Então, nessa perspectiva,
nós não aprendemos,
nem na família, nem na escola,
a lidar com as nossas frustrações.
Todas as vezes que o nosso ego
recebe um "não" ou a suposta...
a nossa suposta busca por realização
de todos os nossos desejos
recebe um "não",
nós não sabemos o que fazer
com aquele "não" e sucumbimos
e elegemos um círculo,
que eu chamo aqui de uma moral,
onde eu mesmo imponho
os meus limites e digo:
"Só pertencem a mim
aqueles que me fazem bem.
Só pertencem a mim
as ideias que me querem bem.
Só pertencem a mim aqueles
que forem iguais a mim".
Vocês entendem o empobrecimento
que essa experiência traz?
Ela leva à criação de adultos
imbecis e infantis.
São adultos que não aprenderam a cair,
e, portanto, não aprenderam a se reerguer.
Ao contrário dessa outra matriz,
eu chamo essa aqui de matriz
de realização de desejos.
E essa aqui eu chamo de matriz
de realização de propósitos.
Na matriz de realização de propósitos,
o que eu tenho é um ser
humano que aprendeu,
como a gente costuma dizer
no Kundalini Yoga ou no Sikh Dahrma,
a gente tem um termo pra isso
que se chama "jivan mukta",
que significa "morrer em vida".
Nós aprendemos tantas vezes
a morrer em vida,
nós aprendemos tantas vezes
a lidar com a nossa própria frustração,
que quando a gente retoma a nossa vida,
seguramente nós somos mais autênticos,
seguramente nós somos mais fortes
e seguramente nós somos mais singulares.
Alguém me perguntava ontem
o que me faz plural,
e o que me faz plural
é a minha singularidade.
Então, esse paradoxo é a coisa
mais maravilhosa da vida
e é onde, por exemplo, no Kundalini Yoga,
nós jamais abrimos mão
de qualquer paradoxo.
Ele é a base pulsante da nossa vida.
É da mesma maneira que nós temos
nessas duas matrizes aqui,
uma experiência de morrer em vida,
que me faz muito apta
a apreciar o desconhecido,
me faz muito aberta ao desconhecido.
E é justamente essa abertura
que eu tenho ao desconhecido
que me faz fazer o que Platão
sugeriu tantos milênios atrás.
E aqui nós criamos, na verdade, uma ética.
Ao contrário de uma moral, essa ética é:
"Eu não quero só estar em mim.
Eu quero estar no outro também,
porque o desconhecido
do outro me é importante,
e é no desconhecido do outro,
e na contradição do outro,
que eu vou aprender mais sobre mim".
Então, basicamente essas duas matrizes,
elas acolhem toda a ideia
que o mundo moderno tem
de liberdade ou de prisão.
E aí, é óbvio que nos restam
dois caminhos,
eles são bem simples.
Eu tentei sintetizar pra dar
a vocês um pouco de uma ideia
muito complexa.
Fazê-la ficar muito fácil
de ser digerida,
que é essa ideia de você se colocar
numa determinada situação,
e você ter dois caminhos:
ou você torna-se um prisioneiro
das demandas infindáveis do seu ego,
e você coloca todo o seu
combustível emocional
a responder essas demandas do ego,
e eu não tenho nada contra o ego,
inclusive eu acho muito bom.
Se nós somos vivos,
nós somos vivos porque nós temos um ego.
Mas uma coisa é o ego
apartado de um espírito,
é aquele que busca instantaneamente,
imediatamente, um conforto emocional,
que me faz ficar muito frágil.
Então, a minha roda de satisfação
de desejos imediatos,
ela vai me levar pra uma busca
muito paranoica de segurança,
porque eu não tenho segurança em mim
e eu tenho que buscar a segurança
em todos aqueles que se aproximam.
Todo o desconhecido que se aproxima de mim
tem que me garantir
que eu estarei seguro com ele,
se vocês entendem
a mudança de perspectiva.
Só pertence a mim aqueles
que me dão conforto e segurança.
Então, eu aprendi como bebê a fazer birras
e como adulto eu continuo dramatizando
para alcançar aquilo que eu quero.
A outra rota possível
é a rota onde eu pego
todo esse combustível emocional
e coloco ele a serviço do meu ímpeto.
Eu coloco ele a serviço
da minha singularidade.
da minha disposição
a romper todo tipo de barreira
e me apaixonar e me tornar cada vez mais
apaixonada pela experiência.
Essa condição, ela só é possível
porque pra alma,
ao contrário do ego,
só existe um motivador: é a experiência.
E não uma garantia prévia
de que a experiência será boa;
para a alma isso pouco importa.
A alma é o desconhecido,
ela é o infinito.
Pra ela, quanto mais experiências,
mais eu vou saber do meu desconhecido
e mais eu vou ficar aberta
pro desconhecido imediatamente
à minha frente, que é o outro.
Eu não preciso ir
pras estrelas e pro universo.
Eu posso ir justamente
no céu à minha frente,
que é o outro.
E assim...
pra eu finalizar com vocês,
eu acho que
o teste do grau da minha liberdade
não está no quanto eu conheço
intelectualmente da liberdade
e o quanto eu falo dela.
O teste da minha liberdade
é um teste da minha espiritualidade,
é um teste do meu espírito.
Ele quer dizer o seguinte:
quando eu for confrontada pelo finito
mais insolente,
mais radical,
que é o da dor e do sofrimento,
se eu encontro esse finito
que é colocado diante de mim,
com o meu finito ou com o meu infinito?
Se eu for encontrar
o finito do desconforto,
da dor,
da contradição com o meu finito,
com certeza eu vou
recrudescer no meu círculo,
eu vou cristalizar
no meu modelo de passado
e vou fazer do meu modelo
de passado o meu futuro.
Mas se ao contrário,
eu encontro esse finito doloroso,
insofismável,
com o meu infinito,
eu tenho uma chance de fazer
o que a evolução espera de mim,
que é que eu mude,
que eu me adapte,
que eu me renove
e que eu acorde de um tombo
e me sinta uma pessoa viva
e absolutamente nova.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos)(Vivas)
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)